en serrana el coronavirus tiene los días
contados y no solo por la labor de
desinfección que el equipo municipal
realiza desde hace un año
hace un mes las escuelas se han
convertido en centros de vacunación el
instituto butantán lleva a cabo un
experimento científico sin precedentes
vacunar a 28 mil voluntarios es decir el
97 por ciento de la población adulta
esta semana aplica la segunda dosis
significa significa mucho fue muy bueno
que haya acontecido porque vamos a
quedar inmunizados nos vamos a librar de
esta enfermedad el libro de su dueño se
cerrará es una ciudad dormitorio y sus
habitantes circulan en toda la región
para trabajar desde el inicio de la
pandemia registró un porcentaje muy alto
de contagios por eso fue escogida para
el estudio no somos privilegiados y
agradecemos mucho este proyecto que nos
está ayudando en este momento este
momento éste es el cuartel general del
instituto butantán en serrana desde esta
sala un equipo de médicos e infectólogos
coordina una investigación pionera
serra no fue subdividida en 25 pequeñas
áreas estamos analizando la cobertura
inmunológica de cada una de estas áreas
para determinar si eso tiene relación
con la inmunidad de rebaño y con la
reducción de casos graves y
hospitalización a los internación este
estudio también intenta determinar cuán
eficaz es la vacuna contra las
mutaciones de coronavirus el alcalde de
serrana se muestra muy optimista
hoy en el municipio ya tenemos en torno
de un 55 por ciento de disminución de
los casos graves creemos que es un
resultado bastante importante si tenemos
en cuenta que todavía no acabamos el
segundo ciclo de vacunación sólo el 11
de abril concluye este experimento de
vacunación masiva los resultados pueden
influir en la lucha contra el cob y en
brasil y en todo el mundo israel que ha
sido un ejemplo en la vacunación ha
mostrado interés por ese estudio
mientras los habitantes de serranas
siguen cumpliendo la cuarentena
obligatoria en el estado de sao paulo